Evan: "Alfonso asks: I have doubt.  I'm starting my company but I'm 18.  I think that people won't take me seriously.  How can I get over this?
Hi Alfonso.
You gotta believe!
It's behind Evan.  Honestly,.  You believe.
There's a few things.  One, social media.
You can be whoever you want to be.  In terms of social media.
In terms of social media.
You can build a presence. You can build a brand..  You can build awesome products.
You can build awesome products.
I think in the world of social media; the digital economy
Great products win markets!
So if you have a product idea
Then, there's nothing stopping you.
If it's a services business
Even a face to face business
Then I think people are going to buy your enthusiasm
People are going to buy your commitment and energy!
I know a couple of guys who are young.
They are sub 21. And they started a services business
They actually said "If you believe what I say and I could do a great job for you.
I think I could learn really quickly.  I have a great work ethic
I got a great attitude.
Why don't you take me on for two weeks? Just on expenses.
And pay me nothing.  And then at the end of the two weeks we'll prove ourselves.
And they have done similar sorts of things with their people.
So that's almost like try before you buy.
So if you've got any anxieties about being 16 years old and number one put them away!
Number two is build up your confidence and conviction.
Because there's a lot of people who are 16 year old who are changing the world
Just a couple of examples
I think it was a Forbes article.
Someone made a pen.
Who's done loads of stuff
He's given free TedTalks
Started loads of stuff around a clothing company.
An environmental activitst
And WoooW at the age of 16?  It's just incredible!
You just couldn't have imagined that.
I dont think age is a barrier
Age is something you should gonna think tremendous energy tremendous passion, you got a big idea
People will back you if you back yourself
Evan:  I can relate.  When I was 19 I had my first software company.
I was selling the guys 3 times my age who had Ph'd
And I didn't have a single background in Science.  I'm selling to Scientist
It took me a while to get over it
I tried to do everything by email
I thought that if I talked on the phone they'll know i'm to young
They won't take me seriously.
It was until I realized  that
These guys actually need me
I can provide value to them!
And at the end of the day that's all they care about
All they care about is "Can you help me with the problem I am facing right now?"
Once I understood that
it give me a lot more confidence to be able to talk to people
Even later, as I started working with brands.
One of the first companies I worked with was Microsoft.
I was twenty something
And I thought "Wow, why would Microsoft want to work with me  They are Micor soft.?"
They know everything.  And I am just some young punk kid.
And then I started talking them and  I realized
"These guys need my help!" *laughs*
I can help them!
Just having confidence in your ability
Knowing that all they  deep down care about
is that you can provide value to them and help them
Once you understand that
At least for me, the the age fear
kind of went away
With that Evan you and I both know
Whatever age you are
Any really smart kids can go into a business
and improve it.
When you run a business for any period of time
You just either become complacent
Or just do the same things you do everyday
And I think this complacency stiffles innovation
So people accept the status quo
I just think new pairs of eyes with
tremendous enthusiams
And no kind of anxiety about changing stuff
Could make massive difference
Back yourself.  Believe in yourself
Like you Evan.  When I was 16 I was selling ice creams
selling ice creams
on the beachfront
And I tell you what
It paid for my college education.
I couldn't believe
how much margin there was in ice creams.
When used to sell these, equivalent to Canadian
it was probably at the time
This is a long time ago
It was about a dollar
And I used to buy this stuff in the ice cream and the cone
The actual unit price of these ice creams was probably about two cents
was probably about two cents
I just couldn't believe
the profit margins in ice creams
Obviously if you didn't hit it right
it was a really hot day
there was a lot of wastage
I'll be candid with you guys
When it was a rainy day
No one came to the little booth on the sea front
booth on the sea front
What I had to do was get out the boat
go and sell the ice creams
to whoever was around
and you find out as well
Stuff happens in your head
People aren't going to buy this
They don't want to talk to me
They are visitjng with their families
But when you go up to people and just have a conversation
It's just amazing how people are welcoming
And people will want to buy stuff
Especially from young people! People back young people
People want young people to be successful
If you believe in yourself
That is contagious!
That belief and conviction spreads like
a beautiful affection of love
And you know what it's like Evan
The first sell, the second one
gets easier, the third one
gets easier
The fourth family is easier
Everyone you do is easier
With all thesee things
Just take the first step.
Believe in yourself
About yourself
Have no fear.
And then you just stop listening to those crazy voices in your head
That tell you; "You can!"
Because you can.